how do you feel
happy glorious Monday before we get to
all the fun stuff I.E rubbing the Super
Bowl loss and Jesse Waters ugly fat face
first we're going to talk about crime
and a really bad one specifically
involving Jen Angel she's the
progressive owner of angel cakes a
bakery in Oakland California she was
savagely murdered this week robbed by
two thieves who smashed her car window
ran off with her purse She chased after
the Duo's car but got caught in the car
door dragged to her death terrible
terrible story it kind of gets worse
because her family and her friends are
urging the police not to jail her
killers
hey they're listening oh they're here
yeah because they claim it would not
align with her beliefs in something
called restorative justice and also
because they're idiots
her murderers are still on the loose but
rather than call for their capture her
friends urged the city to promise not to
make her Killers serve hard time
which is kind of what you do if someone
you hated died but this is restorative
justice a lying phrase that restores
nothing and offers No Justice at all to
anybody it's a strategy to keep thugs
out of jail by claiming someone in the
past got a raw deal so you transfer past
Justice to this current creep even if
he's guilty as Sin using this reasoning
or lack of reasoning you could never
meet out Justice on any brutal crime
ever just say people were treated badly
in the past so let this poor soul go
they claim that imprisoning her
aggressors would prevent actual healing
well you want healing put on Marvin Gaye
actually locking them up for a long time
would promote healing a lot of it by
keeping the perpetrators next victims
away from harm and by the way you think
Angel's friends might be open to having
the perpetrators come live with them
indefinitely how restorative will they
feel when everything they own is
suddenly being sold on Craigslist
including their kids
still they say locking them up would
only perpetuate harm but they don't say
to whom because it's murderers perps who
get away with murder won't think you
know wow that was so nice they didn't
lock me up I won't murder people anymore
now the experience incentivizes them to
kill again to accrue more victims
which is the problem with the entire
system that's abdicated their
responsibility in protecting innocent
from evil
today ideology Trump safety and creates
a parade of victims but also a parade of
idiots
like 1619 project author Nicole Hannah
Jones who complained about drugstores
locking up merchandise in a tweet on
Tuesday so what is 1619 you ask well
it's the number of stupid thing things
this broad says a day
she said quote if you're gonna lock up
everything in the drugstore an already
demeaning shopping experience apparently
it's demeaning to go to a drugstore
at least have enough workers to open up
the cases for all the customers who just
need a razor well she told us too much
I get it we all need a razor now and
again
she ends it with it's just a terrible
shopping experience
oh poor millionaire grifter maybe they
can't afford more workers because their
stuff keeps getting stolen thanks to the
legalization of organized looting
something you clown Justified imagine if
you were beaten to death in a riot
Nicole Hannah Jones would probably
complain about having to walk around the
crime scene
fact is a rise in crime and shoplifting
cases have forced stores to lock up
merch and even shut down stores due to
loss of Revenue and it's types like
Hannah Jones who denied this was a
problem
so now we're locking up deodorant
instead of the people stealing the
deodorant
[Laughter]
and it's on this bozo back in 2020 she
insisted that all the horrible
destruction from the George Floyd
protest was not violence
quote yes it is disturbing to see
property being destroyed it's disturbing
to see people taking property from
stores but these are things
that's true they are things just things
things that people sell to make a living
but nonetheless she's right they're just
things
I guess that's why all those rioters
made sure no one was in all those
buildings before setting them on fire
but about those things what if they're
taken from people and the people they're
taken from try to get them back which is
what Angel did with their purse it begs
the question why did she chase them at
all I mean let them have your money let
them have your purse according to her
friends and family it's exactly what she
would have wanted the restorative
justice activists would say that it's on
her for putting value on her things
which is why they also deserve to be
locked up along with their
antiperspirant if they use it
three years
let's welcome tonight to guests
unlike our air force all his Pilots get
shot down TV Rider and producer Rob Lowe
she spent more time around the pigskin
than a hot dog salesman host of the
sideline sanity podcast Michelle Tafoya
he's what you get if Elton John and
Travis Bickle had a baby host of fox
Across America Jimmy Fallon
and finally lovable is just one of the
many words people never use to describe
her
oh
shut up
first of all
um
Professor I really enjoyed your last
book thank you um and uh thank you for
giving me those extra office hours after
class you know what that's the least I
can do yes for how you uh behaved I
guess I don't have a joke for this it's
horrible that's what people some people
get fired for these jokes yes that's
true that's true but you know what if I
get murdered Rob I would prefer that you
go to the press and say we need to catch
these bastards and put them behind bars
I don't think I'd want anybody on my
side of the family or your side of the
family when we do decide right um to to
say no because that's not your rights
that is not your right yeah I would just
say to one thing if that God forbid
should happen to you I I think what I
will do is call Fox and say so you need
somebody
here you heard if I murdered
him yeah so after professor professor
kangaroo
I think the thing you but what you
mentioned this in your monologue which
is by the way is a super Downer by the
way not a great way to start your show
I'll show business advice start with a
smile but I uh like she actually went
after yes to get her stuff back she
wanted her money back right like so
maybe I don't understand what an
anarchist is because they said she was
an anarchist a person who wants their
money back is not an anarchist right
that person is a capitalist yes exactly
and so it kind of feels like she should
be you know she wanted her money back
that she earned why again is that like
yes that disproves what they were
talking about she would want them it's
my stuff yes it's my stuff damn it by
the way that's completely legit that's a
that's you're allowed to want your stuff
back yeah it's not a bad thing anymore
like yeah she earned that stuff she made
cakes apparently they were good I don't
know I didn't have a cake it's okay I
mean the carbs I'm not yeah yeah it's
like you're dropping a few pounds
but she went after her stuff and I feel
like they should be building a statue to
her but I did like your solution is that
okay we don't prosecute the guys we
catch them and they they they have to
live with you yeah but not with me no no
I just I don't have the room yeah I wish
they had to live with those guys all
right thank you Mr Burl Ives yeah
there's a call back cats going who's
Burl Ives not just Cat by the way not
just cat everyone under 50 is saying I
don't know who this guy is
Michelle when you are like how is it
that Nicole Hannah Jones just heard
about our stuff being locked up at CVS
and Duane Reade and while this has been
going on for two years this tells me
that she never buys her own stuff oh
probably not I mean you know she
probably has a service to do that or has
everything delivered to her home but
getting back to the angel cakes woman
her friend said this is what she would
want yeah she would want these people to
be forgiven and have a different form of
Justice
maybe that's what she told them she
wanted a few weeks ago but I wonder what
she was thinking while they were
dragging her on the sidewalk from the
car yeah do you think maybe she changed
her mind like maybe she thought damn I
was wrong people that are crazy enough
and cruel enough to do this to me they
ought to freaking go to prison but she
never got to tell anyone else that she
changed her mind and her friends are now
saying oh she would have wanted them set
free and restorative justice and all the
rest
and then to Ms Jones in 1619 terrible
phrases a day
um yet this is crazy to call shopping a
demeaning experience and exactly it is
sometimes why well yeah I mean I wear
disguise when I go to some of these jobs
yes yeah and they still don't recognize
you no they know who he is
it's only one guy buying that stuff
that's true it's true
and I get so angry I get home when I
realize I'm out of batteries so I'll go
ahead I'm sorry I don't know what I love
drones
the right drones there we go anyway she
uh you're exactly right they cannot
afford people to open up the stuff
people are getting ripped off I
her head is in the sand or somewhere
yeah that's true that's good whoa yeah
that was hot
which topic I liked the hit um well
listen I mean there's a few things going
on here
um this is all the end result of woke
policy and I like woke by its original
name which was stupid you know what I
mean because it's so stupid okay when
you're trying to create an environment
that has more empathy for the criminal
than the victim but that's where we are
like you think about I'll give you an
example a few weeks ago we did a story
about Minor attracted persons they
didn't want to say pedophile like from
now on it's minor attractive persons
because it's a stigma to pedophiles
anybody who wants to ban the word
pedophile probably a pedophile no is
where I think this would start but I
think the bigger issue is they've all
added up to such like an adverse effect
on life whether it's crime or even the
cost of goods like when you think about
what sucks about going shopping it's not
even that stuff is locked up it's that
we're at a 40-year high in inflation
like you think about eggs right now it
used to be when someone got engaged it
was like he went to Jared but now eggs
are so expensive it's like he went to
Whole Foods oh my God girl he must
really love you he bought you a carton
of eggs and that's where I think we've
seen like this full-on societal
mismanagement but I still stand by the
purchase on the jacket you know you're
right about the eggs I'm actually
they're so expensive I'm freezing them
that was funny I just thought of it now
Greg get Pat myself on the back you know
you you you still shop
yes I'm just saying how idiotic the
person is to act surprised that this is
happening when this is something we've
been dealing with every single day it's
true going to the drugstore is no fun
now it's really bad but it's because of
people like her yeah yeah I've never
been in the drugstore like man I'm
having fun yeah
but I actually don't shop anymore
because of that because it's like you
you don't want to wait for every single
thing you just order your stuff on the
internet or you just use your husband's
toothbrush or whatever I know it's
pretty gross but so am I
um
I don't know I mean we all could have
seen this coming but you can't say
anything because then you're a bigot
apparently even if somebody's killed yes
yeah I mean you know how when people die
they stay dead yeah
okay if this happened to me I'm coming
back yeah
anyone says that about me I will get you
yes no it's I will crawl out of hell and
get you hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else